Multicellular organisms, such as a cat,
have many billions of cells. These
include somatic cells, shown here in
orange, and stem cells, shown here in
green. Somatic cells (from the Greek,
"soma", or body) make up the body of an
organism and are committed to
a specific cell fate. For example, the
skin cell can divide to make more skin
cells, but not muscle cells or other
types of cells. In contrast,
pluripotent stem cells ("pluri" means
several, while "potent" means to be
able) can make any kind of cell, for
example, both skin and muscle cells.
Pluripotent stem cells exist as part of
normal development embryos, but they do
not exist in adults. So is it possible
to give adults pluripotent stem cells?
In 2012, Dr. Shinya Yamanaka won the
Nobel Prize for discovering that adding
the four genes, Myc, Oct3/4, Sox2, and
Klf4, into somatic cells leads to
induced pluripotent stem cells, or
iPSCs.
Why is this so important in medicine?
Because iPSCs can grow continuously and
give rise to every other cell type in
the body.
It can be used to replace damaged cells
and tissues, such as in the case of
muscle damage, contributing to the
field of regenerative medicine. Since
iPSCs can be derived from adult somatic
cells, each individual patient could
have their own stem cell line for organ
transplants, for example, to get a new
liver. In addition, iPSCs can be used
to test what specific treatment works
best for individual patients,
contributing to the field of
personalized medicine.